il était une fois
dans une cité lointaine
un quartier son nom cité washington ait
dit
leizer
savez vous bonjour une banque pour avoir
ce risque précis aujourd'hui j'en ai eu
ma b
c'est l'histoire d'un quartier en voie
de disparition
est une tache sur ton t-shirt
on avait tous une soignies temps et pour
réaliser nos rêves
il fallait continuer à se débrouiller
[Musique]
je veux voir le monde avec ses yeux ils
disent qu'ils vont virer tous les
mineurs clandestins il est temps que se
faire entendre
on a doit affirmer notre dignité par de
petits gestes des petits détails qu'il
montre aux autres connaît pas invisible
est en train de frôler tu réussi ni à
moi parce que contrairement à moi tu
vois un avenir
mais n'ont pas fait ça hier soir
on me disait
si tu travailles dur
et si tu es honnête tu gagneras de
l'argent les choses se feront des prêts
j'ai mis de l'argent de côté pendant des
années pour se relancer dès huit garçons
week-end là ça se sent
[Musique]
c'est du délire
mes années les plus rock
tu me suis bâti mentir elles m'ont
soigné
ici
à washington
on le sait
et moi c'est ton m
[Musique]